the passing
the way guys reacted to it i'm still in
shock when that happened that day
it seemed like the world stopped to have
it happen so
tragically it was one of those moments
that i think shook the world
it's terribly sad what happened but you
know his memories don't live on not just
through basketball but you know to the
people he brought into his game
welcome to the kobe show
the fiercest of all competitors he was a
superhero on the basketball court one of
the best players to
ever lace it up back to back to back
five
nba titles in mvp he brought his own
style his own mindset to the game he
never took a night off
he competed every possession made people
who hated him spent a lot of money to
come watch him so that's when you know
you're
[Music]
he is hard great believe the biggest
thing that everybody you know admired
about kobe was the competitiveness
an all-time winner that represented the
toughness and play through everything
type of mindset take big shots make big
shots
he was one of the hardest working guys
that you ever wanted me i've never seen
anybody work like that yeah i felt like
he was just
invincible that's kobe bryant there we
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
go
kobe was the swaggy kobe young athletic
having fun
wear a chain dunk on you throw lobs to
shack
favorite kobe moment we were playing the
dimmer nuggets i would yell out watch
the press
and he would look at me like and the
smile would come over his face because
he knew i saw something he got the full
court pass and wrapped him on his back
and did the reverse dunk
[Applause]
what did i just see i was like see
listen to me i take you places
favorite moment from kobe's career i
remember watching the right elbow pull
up against the phoenix suns bryant for
the win
copy number eight would shoot 27 times
this quarter if i got to win this game
kobe bryant pulls up for the shot and
hits the basket
with 2.6 to go obviously remember the 81
point game he had 81 points in the game
[Applause]
players talk about being in the zone he
was in a super zone he could not miss
ladies and gentlemen
you have witnessed the second greatest
scoring performance in nba history
i just remember thinking that it wasn't
even real it was amazing to watch
the lakers repeat back-to-back titles
bryant the drive
[Applause]
number 24 was a lot more determined he
was locked in he was focused that real
alpha's not taking any prisoners
my favorite kobe moment matt barnes was
taking the ball to bounce and he faked
the pass and bounced at kobe's face and
he didn't flinch
blink or anything that's when he turned
into a basketball genius
and became unstoppable
[Music]
he is yes he's on fire
the mama my mentality is real
laser sharp focus showing up every day
willing to work
kobe slithers
[Applause]
it's a level of relentlessness passion
work ethic that's just
unmatched that's what mambas do they
don't back down at the end of the day
what it allowed him to do is will
himself
and will his team to victories to
championships it was almost
super human that is just greatness
personified a lot of people love kobe
kobe was a leader of our game
inspired a whole generation of
basketball players he was someone that
everyone looks up to especially
this generation of players so in the
words of kobe bryant
mamba out but in the words of us not
forgotten
live on brother koby's impact on the
league is extraordinary he's definitely
one of the most inspirational
basketball players i've ever grew up
watching he made it okay to be obsessed
with basketball
and to just put everything you had into
the game for him to
just have the mindset of wanting to help
others in the younger generation
was really special he's a role model for
so many kids he's like their superman he
was our generation of michael jordan
we are now the people carrying the torch
and we're influenced very heavily by
his play and his mentality the game will
forever be indebted to him
foreign